(audience applauding)
- All right.
And we have someone very special
who requested that song in particular.
He is the host of "Adam Eats the 80s".
Give it up for Adam Richmond.
(audience cheering)
(guitar music)
What's up Adam?
- What's up Kelly?
- Oh my gosh.
I brought you my country
western glitz and glamor.
Do you see my shoulder pads, dude?
I look so-
- [Adam] You look
amazing, you look amazing.
- I look so good with my shoulder pads.
(audience cheering)
We're gonna talk about your-
- Chef's kiss.
- Thank you.
We're gonna talk about
your show in a second,
but first why do you love that song?
- My dad.
This is actually a
picture of him right here.
My dad may he rest in peace,
was a big country fan.
My first concert was the Statler Brothers.
- [Kelly] Oh wow.
- And I grew up hearing him
play Ronnie Milsap songs.
I think people nowadays don't
realize how popular he was,
but from like 74 to 78
he had something like
seven number one hits.
And so I've always loved his music.
I've always loved him.
(audience applauds)
- And it's just really
special to hear you sing it.
- I love it.
He could've named that
smokey mountain rain too.
I'm just saying there's
another song there.
But tell us about your new show.
It's about food in the 80's, right?
- Correct. So "Adam Eats
the 80s" is looking back
at this incredibly dynamic and energetic
and incredible decade through the prism
of food and looking at your audience.
They already know the fashion was amazing.
The fads, the big hair,
the big shoulder pads,
but people don't realize
that it changed American food forever.
There were brands that
emerged that became national
and global icons.
And it also, between the
invention of the microwave,
between fast food and
drive thrus proliferating,
between Reagan saying you could
advertise directly to kids.
So you sugar cereals
with video game scenes
- So wait, I have a question though.
Wait, do you have like
a favorite 80s candy?
- Yes. There's so many candies I love,
but I think that in '84,
Nerds was actually voted Candy
of the Year.
(audience cheering)
And people don't realize
how fascinating the story
behind Nerds was.
This was the company
that had licensed the Willy Wonka brand.
And one scientist saw the little bits
of Everlasting Gobstopper in
the bottom of the machine.
And he said, let's, let's coat
these little hardened bits
of sweetened sugar with ascorbic acid.
Make 'em sour.
Make 'em fruity.
- [Kelly] What?!
- And the Everlasting
Gobstopper became the Nerd,
and those little designs on the package.
I think I sent you guys some.
Those little designs,
the graphic designer used
to doodle them on his desk,
and they just decided, hey,
let's just make these the logo.
- This is brand new information.
(audience applauds)
I did not know that that's what Nerds was.
I love Nerds.
- In fact, one of the scientists,
They're so good.
One of the scientists'
kids actually named them.
So you can't blame it.
(audience cheering)
(Kelly laughs)
All right.
Well, wait, we have a clip
of "Adam eats the 80s".
Take a look.
- This is what I do for you.
(guitar track)
The 1980s was a deliciously doughy decade.
You were either making dough,
baking dough or eating it.
Whether it was Auntie
Anne's decision to expand
into malls and stick
with their recipe for all
of these years or Domino's
attempting to cut a slice
of the breakfast market
with a pizza gone too soon.
The echoes of the 80s
can still be heard today.
And some of them are really, really tasty.
- Thank you so much, Adam.
I love you.
(audience cheers)
Come back on my show.
- I love you, too.